nos piden que simplifiquemos el
logaritmo en base 5 de x al cubo y bueno
para simplificar esta expresión que
tengo aquí voy a usar una de las
propiedades de los logaritmos que vimos
en los vídeos pasados y la propiedad que
voy a usar es la siguiente que sería muy
bueno que le apuntaremos una vez la
propiedad dice lo siguiente si yo me
tomo el logaritmo en base x de no sé de
elevado las etapas y de james elevado a
la potencia z esto es igual a la
potencia baja multiplicando logaritmo y
me queda zeta que multiplica al
logaritmo en base x de james muy bien si
utilizamos esta misma propiedad lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que la
potencia va a bajar multiplicando a
logaritmo y ya con esto vamos a poder
simplificar esta expresión que tenemos
aquí al lado lo único que hay que hacer
es bajar la potencia multiplicando a mi
logaritmo así que fíjate bien tengo aquí
logaritmo en base 5 la base 5 de x
elevado al cubo como podemos simplificar
o convertir esta misma expresión en una
equivalente bueno si yo pongo que estos
logaritmos
él tuvo la potencia lo que va a hacer es
bajar te das cuenta por tanto esto me va
a quedar como 3 déjame ponerlo con otro
color como tres que multiplican al
logaritmo en base 5 recuerda que la base
se mantiene de x x ya sin potencia
porque lo que pasó con la potencia
porque bajó multiplicando a logaritmo
paso la potencia al inicio multiplicando
muy bien y seguramente te estás
preguntando de dónde sale esta propiedad
así que vamos a intentar ver de dónde
puede salir esta propiedad supongamos
que yo tengo a la siguiente expresión ha
elevado a la b igual hace esto estamos
en si ha elevado la b es igual a cero si
yo uso la misma expresión pero esta vez
representada en forma logarítmica es
decir su expresión equivalente a que
llegaría a que el logaritmo en base a de
c es igual a b recuerda que lo podemos
ver la siguiente manera ha elevado a qué
potencia me da c y las respuestas ven si
te das cuenta que tengo una ecuación que
es exponencial una ecuación
exponencial mientras que aquí abajo
tengo una ecuación lugar étnica pero
bueno ahora a continuación lo que va a
hacer es fijarme en la parte de arriba y
en la parte de arriba lo que voy a hacer
es y voy a elevar ambas partes a la
potencia de así que déjenme copiarlo
aquí ha elevado la b es igual a cm y
ambas partes lo voy a elevar a la
potencia de ambas partes al ponerlo como
de minúscula para que no nos confundamos
o está como b mayúscula no no mejor todo
en minúsculas porque si no nos vamos a
confundir bastante entre minúsculas y
mayúsculas así que aquí una d minúscula
déjenme poner el mismo color esto aquí
le voy a poner una d minúscula y que me
queda de esto utilizamos las propiedades
de los exponentes bueno recuerda que si
yo tengo una base elevada a una potencia
y todo esto a su vez elevado a otra
potencia las potencias pueden pasar
multiplicándose entonces esto no
quedaría como a elevado a la b por de
las potencias se van a pasar
multiplicando y eso me va a servir
bastante entonces esto es igual a quien
déjame ponerlo aquí
voy a poner con color verde no no no
mejor déjenme poner otro color porque si
nos vamos a confundir con este color
verde que tengo aquí así que déjenme
guardar todo esto y dejarlo mejor
ponerlo con este otro color me agrada
entonces aquí voy a poner ha elevado a
la bdm ha elevado al apedem es igual a c
elevado al ave muy bien y si ahora
quiero escribir a esta misma ecuación el
lenguaje de logaritmos como me quedaría
pues no hay que espantar nos es
exactamente lo mismo que poner logaritmo
en base a recuerda que era la base que
veníamos utilizando de quien del lado
derecho es decir de ese elevadora de
esto tiene que ser igual a la potencia
de d recuerda que lo puedes ver cómo ha
elevado a que potencia me da se den y la
respuesta es vd muy bien yo tengo que el
logaritmo en base a de c elevado la
desigualdad de de que te parece si ahora
sustituyó el valor de bp porque yo sé
que b es igual al logaritmo en base a de
c lo voy a poner justo aquí lo voy a
sustituir y que me va a quedar bueno me
queda el logaritmo en base a
elevado a la de esto es igual a vídeo
dicho de otra manera a depor b es lo
mismo mientras voy a poner de que
multiplica a b pero ves el logaritmo en
base a de c y te crees aquí ya tengo la
prueba de esta propiedad que estábamos
utilizando para simplificar esta
expresión con la que empezamos logaritmo
en base a desea laden es exactamente lo
mismo que de veces el lugar y nombrase
adc